so pretty much full s and problems
apologies i have apologies for
scattering drain turn out in and
counselors jensen substitute members
I've got cast ashore assuming cathode
ray counselors-licensed a simple
counselor mounting and counsel families
up to you Catherine ebook colada and
where are you now have quietly please
for counsel human version online
division okay so say is there any other
projects cutting your members attending
there some trapping it again you've also
in the minutes of the last meeting you
too except those that letter example is
ridiculous okay declarations intimately
first but we're looking at they make is
the health options also introduced
argument amongst man I lounge em bubbly
cancer we would be a lot like you work
the nelson piquet like it
got a man down in synergy between a very
interesting project into such 1 i've
done a must have mixed but and in my
personal use I've been very pleased with
the way that officers staff and other
members have worked together I'd like to
keep my thanks to the mall and I think
you from very very well as you see in
the report we have them to several ideas
for promoting and using the old house
group services into other venues see
similar again and please have helped us
in a bit deliberations and basically a
lot to push over there max to do the
technical stuff okay I thank you a
couple family members on get just lie
back down Catholic the fields were
they get to feed members office is
working so close get on this project the
working too close together to explain to
conclusions / kappa those words thank
you sir so the report before you see the
outline the potential options for the
old house or to seek member agreement to
take forward the proposed options and as
you'll know the old mouse is a real
Prime council asset grain to start
listed in the conservation areas and
it's a real real prime access account so
in social we do right by and maximize
each use for the accent clothing some
staff being combination moves some
changes for that as you may know the old
house is no longer uses permanent office
spokeswoman as an interim measure help
set up some pcs in there that is used
the hottest environment external order
in their liquid gasoline happens and we
still couldn't use it for calls other
smaller events as well going forward and
meetings as well we've got users
intensely than what before for some
profits for search space working space
so that ends we set up a project working
group members officers working together
to start the best together various
options for the answer and again leak
and angle of business plan maximize our
assets making sure those are all times
Rahman as Catholic with your mentioned
we visited some local listed buildings
in the area as part of the research
phase to try and get get some good ideas
are houses approach the issue of making
a lot of times there's an accent and the
sport made two options throughout report
all this in the report in detail I won't
go through a wall in detail but juices
will summarize we flipped everything for
what things at civil ceremony so it's
exactly which sunscreen and in the
report we also looked at conference or
meeting room use heritage juices and a
moving on to leave
options and finally locks and
potentially selling out there so it
could look the whole range of whole
spectrum make sure we cover all that all
the options available to them we also
then complete the details swot analysis
all the audio different scenario we also
carried on with the most variable
options looking at the financial
analysis working planning our specimens
like one seeing how it would be most
favorably taken forward which will
return the best financial plan for the
authority looking at the various options
you'll see they live at various levels
of reserve the council and the main
things are coming fountain looks cool
it's also worth mentioning that we also
result in different levels of control
and using the assets for the council for
example civil ceremony with a good
degree of flexibility continued use
other uses be that meet these mop of the
space right through the lease options
obviously lacks control and also
reducing the ability to profit forward I
mean to be still currently yet continue
acting to the old house scene charges
are also mentioned in the reports the
north lot of research the competitors
and locally in the further build and
actually found in appendix to and look
for such as a the options are listed but
just in summary the group concluded that
a combination of civil ceremonies and
meeting removes would label the council
to retain the accent for his own
services develop a revenue stream but
also develop other offers going forward
such a terrible usage and forwards etc
we felt the the app that make you very
attractive civil charming venue and
again appendix 1 these are pictures and
report of how the and the air tactic is
looks and Tracy this is build on the on
the success of the rate women so much
army service taking all that learning we
all you have
the wedding's of the windmill already
that's building on expertise you already
have and the real good reputation of
actually developed at last five or six
years of have a license of the other
women we also build on the upper moving
forward looking at productive breakout
rooms and yelled out the things I've
rivals with reception rooms even length
of age looking the garden option for
Markie hi that type of thing at a later
phase off to become established we also
considers how that could potential for
local businesses because potentially do
some bills local businesses to support
them in the development the service that
could be catering photography other
packages as well as prostitution having
to deliver to work with them to develop
their local business needs as well the
creature thing for us we felt that if we
took that option forward it was we could
retain the asset this current condition
for all the use of example meeting rooms
and the offers a space and desk as well
as required as well a more flexible
option we did look at the commercial
lease option also in the report so that
would sell to give us a guarantee rental
income I would have to find phone with
the need for potential break clauses and
due consideration to the other councils
ongoing asset projects and how that
could impact on that option but all SATA
consider if that option taken forward
how that will no longer allow the active
available for the public in terms of
schools and public opening something we
still do company I know it was well as
well attended the file option it
mentioned report not being recommended
just said many times before capsule seat
can't we use the fund ongoing services
it's not something different do at this
time also there goes against the the
overarching objective of the council's
set strategy the moment and I've been
standing the maxim are counter the
distance summary it's a good opportunity
for the council to look at how we
develop the old town to expand the
existing already well respected and well
run
so many servers generate a new revenue
stream for the authority but also retain
me access other purposes should we want
to go forward that's just a brief
summary before perhaps take any
questions and there are members of
wedding theme here today as well so I
feel free to exact times you wish to be
with ok first was scary oh thank you
just to say thanks to that I'm looking
at the figures here going in order form
page 86 my 5 and some figures relating
to the season sharing the option yeah
can I ask you also said that it still
retain it as a occasional of issues that
between those figures if you like to
leave supply out there are not included
in that so that's additional to these
figures is that correct we can still
retain for our own use and sound proper
expecting by that those pieces you said
about serve all did you know that sort
of thing sorry but yes and the other
things about your certificate fool look
at that well in weddings I mean the
window for example we have 50 years a
good number you want to leave the
service capacity there are other users
but you are they're hiring out the
spaces on a poor basically still look at
driving mode for the fantasies of
admission is it for the whole building
yet the think in the moments is that
what used to be the main meter in the
Old Hall so the central room as you as
you see on the screen that ruler would
be to the main civil shown any room on a
small room that's fine it's in mind what
we do the windmill whenever works very
very well that would be the offer we've
been looking to break out rooms so the
old she protect office on the first laws
of right if you look at the room
competitive royal suite for an
additional fee potentially one of the
old aniseed support themed rooms can be
a reception room for doing that I the
same for no additional fee so that's
efficient ality in there some ups sum up
those we kazoo develop that option I
think it will give a couple of the
options that sort of one or many they
want to what we find the women is this
is you stop talk about the options
normally like
oxygen thank you very much signature
making cherry can be questioned what
would happen if these figures are not
delivered as the project progressing
what's happening up there thank you the
in the figures are put in their aura
Tibor think I'm say that first of all I
think based on experience the windmill
we ran that with religious my standing
starts and we have no experience in the
area tools and we're at we have seven in
the first year moving up to I think 26
million up to 55 now so i think it's
showing some some some good growth that
we will would be some of the back of
that using my experience we already have
some cotton we can live this if we don't
in terms of the outline the figures are
listed any use we do i think we're going
to look at the the app is all they
already listed so i think that's it
anyway the outlay in terms of our saw
something license is something pumpkin
pounds of relatively small or the sound
we could we could get back I'd look
additional marketing figures are things
included but I'm confident we can we can
live a bigger okay thank you can't uh
sure yeah you mentioned the further down
the road maps with the Amalfi yes how
much so that in the road to you anxious
patent I appreciate that might depend on
it we hiked up I i actually think so if
you will that in the calculor type fun
you know you can have a package you've
got the girl New York Amalfi I came to
think that you know him here and I was
on sighs I go to the mill and they go to
the old school yesterday jump job done I
don't know I done a lot with that well
as to where they would go if they came
out nothing I don't know that means is
there somewhere else they did a reason
people don't actually usually one get a
contract marzo
just come out and go somewhere never
driven them know the correct in psychic
lady Rochford hotel which is the other
yoga bank up oh yeah i mean i've done
that i would suggest is we can go in the
show we go to get something we call very
soon arose ammonia in another line
technical so i think and yes saying i
think Ross hotel is the obvious link for
the for the large reception if you want
to do in raising currently I think we
just felt that so we want to make sure
we we argue in a lavish a market in the
early yeah I don't see why you have a
tubing and plenty next someone's looking
at we weren't ish you're looking at
maybe not to use to the summer months
for shorter time period at first of a
few weeks maybe offering a the diverse
of the 13 and 10 to 15 years as sort of
a sort of a limited offer in terms of
encouragement of them so as we've taken
up so we can look about as well link to
map the road uses of course there was
something challenge quality since I mean
eruption seen as well so yeah but I them
to take off or what its decision to the
ground service is something that we had
discussed here oh yeah I mean more
costly hiring or even buying a marquee
and then it's available for the
counselors at home just to actually
other venues in the area the freight
house tied my daughter's wedding
reception and right after that the
minute I saw one people it was next one
is to Catalina I think it's like that's
a report they going to think of
everything it will incorporate lots of
office alone then minutes anything
animations kilos it alone and he is very
important because
really important and the other thing was
done people are they going to be the
extra Sparkle at sewing sensors and
staffing costs we've included that
within the expenditure the way runs of
the windmill if you have civil so many
systems are paid on a mendacious so the
expansion's cover by income belt energy
wedding buttons increase haven't covered
expenditures yet will be Cyclops they
include in the report so would have been
a true self employed all using if using
the thing starts say [ __ ] like that
additional role and we look to develop
the numbers you have now to cover the
other wat reserves Apple since you catch
all right just a couple of fishermen
push you start this very indicate what
might work for approval and family
weddings of building 60 servings in 72
the half thousand pounds be into 20 22
inch Twitter on so how many wedding
having cerebral atrophy that 2020 on
figure the same thing a half that
equates to 25 if you take that being the
maxim 700-pound figure with proposed
that be the season some time itself
lasted two additional fees we could
charge as well with a vengeance on that
mean that's based on for the modest
growth looking what the women was
achieved with a bit but this
announcement is lethal I'm just going to
option G you've got some expenditure in
there some of you well we look to have
to start off with we got 5,000 pounds a
year subscribe thousand pounds no
prepping right there I think that we
felt and from our sponsor meeting
tomorrow at that near the age of the
building we would have to acquire some
capital investment going forward and it
would help in the go check and release
if we will take on some that I
original Eclipse is very very exciting
it may be I think we should we go would
have been nice divorce is a job for me
to correct result that they're worth
case so that we happened get different
options potential reminder to help very
much worse can request physic given
potential just answer the question or a
phenol constituents booking for consul
shall deal I didn't look ringmer and run
faster I haven't had an inversion with
costings & % brooches in fortuna cocking
give back plant and Michael but I will
argaman chase them if not tomorrow I was
get one next to it next week and I'll
get them to you right so you've got
because I'm sorry that you've we burned
officially concludes geology I've
actually spoken to my stomach look
outside only two got an idea of
something as other folks within every
side effect language of love question
what do you say makes fun of Ramirez
expenditure in the way of the bat
Marquis you could get these in singular
Martinez blower relatively cheap instead
of on the conventional market and I use
an all-weather thing is just clearly an
ideal opportunity for you and they're
relatively cheap I found on what your
expenditures going to being for next
vantage vue amounts or any improvements
to the failure also with the two to have
any Museum part of the patients if you
guys r Oxford or regularly to go in
there in there to it to make it more
interesting and you care but they got
the first question about expenditure I
think it'd be changing the on times we
don't know but they're sorting options
whether it was a hierarchy or alter
alter purchase depending on frequency
something if it's age would have looked
a lot
we go visit for the most approachable
but in terms of as a museum piece in the
ensuing I think it's there's a cool
number of items in their mountains that
the right wing will have a new creation
museum on the second floor off the rocks
of these items in there and if not the
hair they could be displayed in in
watching potentially as part of that it
would maybe actually at the Opera as
well happens about those thoughts
something is that look out you know they
quite at least your groups on Hilton
Head co-op you aware of this from that
the bank you see Elise is going be done
with the unit island as what's been
going on in in the bio documentation in
rochford amazing in the past which the
papers a lot of William to disposal so I
just wanted it that might be something
you might be looking into it sort of
frame up on the wall or something like
that he runs as a college or something
you know that people will be interested
yeah I think we mentioned the report
that say we sorta continue to develop
thought as a moment our max where useful
this is known of the competition in fact
we did also think possibly putting
notice again ground rods with our things
anybody's got any items that they could
lend us the use as a museum full for the
ability thank you I believe what comes
after the county lots of past
outstanding let's do sort of hellish
taller and what we have I think yousa
cello butchered struggle societies
he is not here to come and do that
beneath people of love the place is
passionately aah and so he would love
the ability so we SAT deliver the word
because ovarian of the lovely place
again Thank You chair i'd like i'd like
to ask you a couple of questions about
the table on page 6 15 min see financial
analysis and I may have got it wrong so
I'm going to you that it sounds glad
forcibly keep you you set these options
outta to begin cetera 1 so if I
understood for your presentation but the
main plank is going to be civil
ceremonies of various sorts but he
doesn't rule out using for hire of rooms
in which case if that is correct then of
course the option really use a and B and
it's hopefully all the way and some of
things and if that's the case then those
figures will actually be benefit
officially improved is that what you
said check up on your bike when I think
the recommendation try to teach that and
again the Civil salmon will be the bulk
of it have been the revenue put number
use because of the frequency be in terms
of revenue stream yes sir and is it was
firmly and yes for example the
expenditure in something actors all that
you like yet would would be the same if
it was medium speed balls that would
certainly heart into only using that one
so yes we can combine these options
together would be certainly the best
option and I think I've been leaving
recommendation to look at civil families
and making a musician suggest and then
let the developing pools other when we
can surf after that racial successful to
convince that's going so what's a value
the expenditure of 12,700 which is both
capital and revenue in year one would
incorporate some of the costs if not all
of the costs Lisbet under options be for
expenditure capsule review as well
but includes some of it the active or
what have you mentioned in the first
recommendation would have to do about
clocks a bit of a single cost on what
the clock by phone hey okay just to say
within the recommendation it does
mention about the use certainly one of
the rooms of the Chairman's parley and
so I think that's something that's
interesting in the fact that it may
release the rooms in rayleigh use for
something else and I think that
something that is not actually committed
within the report itself that could be a
potential game they saw that fits and
that an income main maybe or at least
use by ourselves as far as that's
concerned so I think you know this will
sort of drive behind this and i think is
right that we look there's a potential
uses i think the point that was made
about set actually losing it and
partially as a museum as well the sight
of it the only thing of museums are
worrying me and then is potentially very
expensive anybody any authority the runs
a museum will tell you how much it costs
very difficult to get your money back on
a museum so if you're using it for other
things as well multi-view so let that
cleaning like sin and in fact in class
is the author so from that point of view
I think you've got real potential thank
you Kevin so um I just want to
congratulate tournament at each other it
was quite dollar will halt would quite
explicit and I think you don't all
deserve a pat on the back or more
presented its material in question that
obvious fulfilled one of the very
mention there in the other
museums potentially cost more something
that sort fortune-telling is firm museum
has artifacts that is that there are
other people offering multipacks being a
blade potentially they may have our
values and is there any insurance
implications which might add a cost to
service to the project risk if there's
going to be an increasing number of
active access that may potentially had a
significant value I think if we wear
this it is your option we can look at
sir I think if we would go down the road
than a detail would look to run at the
same way we do that the way when the
museum what we use make good use
volunteers and yet something insurance
essentially the artifacts that we we
have an acquisition policy at the women
wear items are properly signed the cross
and I don't you to account so things
that are very clearly documented and
recorded seven to follow the similar way
and professional over their lips and
follow it and same way to join and make
sure we don't full five an issues answer
because happen again that's external
details that they're getting up to get
experience the football how about an
announcement we can then got to get out
anyone questioned Emily just math that's
right you got the insurance do you have
mms if you can shorts fall and ceremony
as if for some reason you had to cancel
it certainly it could be very very
expensive is there a special interest
you can be counted we can check my
insurance terms of insurance or public
liability insurance example that
invented when existing pretty as we know
increase their we don't have insurance
that the other we built for cancellation
example we might want to look at that if
we have good soaking further that we
don't care we have them so if for
instance than subscription your buddies
and you have to cancel somebody's
wedding it could be very expensive
yeah yes I think something need to
consider and to go through so it grows
but we can significant up them to look
at a Latino number of wedding venues
that offer that is an add on extra for
me a lot in the back you either the
bridegroom good night I just as far as
its own identity like what they
different almost I thank you different
some clarity on the recommendation for
it was pending release of the bucket
started outlining occult the things that
makes very big okay we sisters the
response that the budget requirement is
12,700 for optional which I think we are
all exceptionally happy with but that
the option please ten pounds and some of
that is incorporated into the option is
not actually twenty two thousand seven
hundred to what we see action figure
that we're being asked to prove if we
saw the option be included in a box and
I when there's no clarity is what you're
actually asking for channel will be
listed them separately intake members
wish to see the individual options which
include water and rather than a
combination but just to clarify we've
anticipated that approximately 5,000
pound set aside for the access all it in
terms of some adaptations and things
that happens around PACA things like
that so you could from expenditure that
AMD because they 5,000 pounds of being
combined the property the body you're
asking to apply shipping option of
recommendation for seventeen thousand
seven hundred yes it is declared file
included in the 12 7 tripod is included
see that English 10,000 so you would be
half of the 10,000 full 12 7 and five is
so
for half of the 10 pounds of motion be
yes zooming you're doin both grunting
yet but the actors already done one so
I'm even more confused there I've asked
the question option a and you're saying
it's 12 7 you'll say option B is pain
you're saying 5000 of that is in option
a if I how much do you want in total
[ __ ] 74 these are faring servant yes and
5x venture capital and revenue for
option B so it's healthy at 17 seven in
total vision and that's that's what so
I'm not the preferred option alien poke
my nose are they under option A and B
because it's not clear in what we need
to do to clarify recommendation for of
seventeen thousand seven hundred because
if we say as in the report will
authorizing twenty two thousand seven
hundred Thank You mr. Channing we
finally got here and go through another
question camera but it what makes couple
of one's got a small quantities of these
subjects were recently produced in two
thousand in cotton rounds played there
are I found several errors in there we
can find out reporting but what we
thought of doing was something like this
if you can for the rayleigh windmill on
that and in fact it this doctor coughs
please cancel a penny because it's all
paid for on the advertisers the holding
of that journey
definitely want to look at that me sorry
I think I think the cake I think I drop
caps on that bleep the right draw their
copies but we gotta move ok pup cool yes
yes thank you yeah awful good as I can
only do the smoke one straight for me it
sucks i'll read it now let's say there
are several errors in there which i have
picked up and now looking like that ok
just a quickie Genesis term it
personally that there are several
pictures in the old cheese exorcist
about the restoration of the building
etc I want to lose those I think you
actually if you have a sort of heritage
is conservative old pal so the way the
business together so that doesn't take
it within a family life but you know
with a beer in under executive briefing
yes something to what we actually read
the email will be made next chapter is
he a suspect right so captain ok I've
got that's like the footage thing for
the work I've done on this I think
people I know they've been out to a
number of other venues and porters and
very likely we propose an epic so
congratulations to the men that look in
their season photo balanced and extra
job okay let's move on to the
recommendation than being on page seven
and you want these taken the whole
oranges secondly he wants to anything to
figure that
is an attention they are not important
okay all right reduce the budget five
six seven yeah a little bit yeah
probably got the driveway I can okay
right first recommendation develop an
excess strategy or an excess plan for
the old house like to pending the
outcome of one license the old house for
civil settlements and yes I am just like
in two other fellows opinion I I assumed
I'd a deified the assistant director
asst commercial services in complicating
the portfolio love the ex-wife and
portfolio whole community to set the
things of charges for the use of the old
houses Phil's civil service and making
use of external organizations I can form
pending a free release the budget of the
17 is at seven x 17 7 and others yes
okay and outlined in the report in
appendix to the civil ceremony and
meeting reviews about their life and
item five developed the future uses
outlined in the report such as heritage
tours education use and the potential
use of each end
okay Jenny buddy how do that every day
big load up all week